-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
let's get to some good news.
Today gas prices in the U.S.
hit a two-month low
coming in just under $4.50.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That story again --
gas prices are still high.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, gas prices
are on the way down.
This morning,
a White House aide said,
"Good news, Mr. President."
And Biden was like,
"Is today April 1st?"
Of course,
Biden can't catch a break.
Gas prices are finally down,
but thanks to the heat, Gatorade
is now 7 bucks a gallon, yeah.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but it is hot!
It is hot.
-Yeah, how hot is it?
-Not just here in the U.S.,
but there are record
high temperatures
all across the world.
Seriously, it's so hot,
people on TikTok were slapping
each other with tortillas
just for the breeze.
[ Laughter ]
-Oy!
-Pshew!
It's so hot right now,
the Fantasy Suite
on "The Bachelorette"
is just the back
of an ice-cream truck.
Hey!
-Oh, hey, oh!
Mr. Softee!
-Yeah, yeah, that's --
[ Laughter ]
It is so hot,
people are ordering Chipotle
just so the E. coli
can give them the chills.
That's what I'm saying.
People are doing this
'cause that's how hot it is.
All across Europe,
the heat is brutal.
Today actually was
the hottest day in the history
of the U.K.
at 40 degrees Celsius.
Yeah, Americans heard that
and were like,
"Yeah, we have no idea
what that means.
Is that hot? Is that hot?"
Yep, the heat has been breaking
records around the world,
and we're all trying
to beat the --
[ Thunder crashes ]
Oh, what --what is that?
-Yeah, it's in my contract.
If it gets above 95,
I get misted.
-Oh, really?
-I don't want to call you
a loser,
but you should get
a better agent.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Wow.
-Oh. Now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. You're getting --
-Yeah.
-Does that feel good?
Does that feel good?
-Yeah, now I'm cool!
-Yeah! [ Laughs ]
Yeah, you're
definitely cool, buddy.
-My man!
-You're definitely cool.
-I'm blind!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news.
"The Bachelorette" is in
full swing, and if you --
[ Cheers ]
Yeah. Oh, it's good.
If you don't know, now you know.
This season there are not one,
but two Bachelorettes.
[ Audience oohs ]
It might sound weird
to date two girls at once,
but remember it is a show
about dating 32 guys at once.
So just remember.
So, as of last night,
they're down to 21 guys.
Yeah, and I gotta say,
my favorite remaining
contestants are...
Jacob, James, Jason,
Johnny, and Jordan.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying. I just --
One more time.
That's James, Jacob,
Johnny, Jason, and Jordan.
[ Laughter ]
Again, that's Jamie, Jamie,
Jeremiah, Jamarcus, and Jordan.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And just so we're clear,
that's Jibbly, Jobbly, Jasobbly,
Bobobbly, and Jordan.
And finally, one last time.
That's Ja, Jeh, Jer, Juh,
and I forget this guy's name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was...
Last night's episode
was pretty dramatic.
In case you missed it,
here's a re-enactment
with actual words
from the actual show
starring me, Tariq,
and Questlove.
Guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thanks, Jimmy.
I'll be playing Chris,
a contestant
with nefarious intentions.
-And I'll be playing Quincey,
who is about to confront Chris.
-I'll be playing Jordan H.
Alright. Let's get ready.
-My personal perspective
is that if you're in a situation
where there's four people
invited to this Fantasy Suite,
and then the female
in the situation
has sex with someone else,
then I wouldn't be interested
in that person
being the person I'm with.
-Would you vocalize that
to them before Fantasy Suites
or during Fantasy Sites
or -- or after Fantasy Suites?
-Good question.
Well, it would be dependent
on the situation.
-Well, you wouldn't know
the situation.
-Listen. Listen.
-You wouldn't know
the situation!
-Gosh darn it!
I did not say that!
Like, like, I did not --
-Did he not?
Did he not? Did he not?
Did he not?
-Look. Look. Look.
-Did he not?
-Did he not? Did he not?
Did he not? Did he not?
Did he not?
[ Laughter ]
-Look, you're trying
to control it, though.
-Look. I've let you speak.
And I let...him speak.
-I'm just saying,
the way you're saying it
is still rubbing us
the wrong way.
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It's --
It's rubbing you wrong?!
Rubbing you wrong?!
-Oh, my gosh. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Questlove and Tariq, everyone.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No. No. No.
-Switching gears...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Switching gears...
Switching gears...
I read that over -- Very nice.
I read that over the next
few months Toys "R" Us --
Toys "R" Us will open
inside every Macy's store
across the country.
Yeah. Yeah.
They've combined a department
store with a toy store,
or as I like to call it,
a Target.
Well, get this.
Apparently due to inflation,
I don't know
if you guys heard this.
Consumers...
-I didn't hear. What is it?
-Consumers are cutting back
on chocolate purchases.
-What?!
-Yeah.
Well, I guess now that explains
the new Whitman's Sampler
commercial I just saw.
Check this out.
-At times like these,
you need chocolate
you can't resist,
Which is why we're releasing
our brand-new Whitman's Sampler:
No Bull [Bleep],
without all that unnecessary
crap everyone hates.
So say goodbye to cherry
cordials that taste like
fruit dipped in
your grandmother's perfume
or coconut chews that leak out
a weird milky goo.
And let's be straight-up --
no one likes nougat.
Whitman's Sampler:
No Bull [Bleep].
You want bull [bleep],
call Russell Stover.
-I mean, that's just --
Can you believe I saw that?
-Odd. Indeed.
-Hey, guys.
I saw that today
former New York City mayor
Bill de Blasio dropped
out of the race for Congress.
Yeah. He --
[ Applause ]
The hardest part was breaking
the news to his supporter.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
A man in Wisconsin tried to use
a brick to rob a Kay Jewelers.
Did you see this?
But it did not go as planned.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After...
After a few minutes, even
the security guard was like,
"Here, let me try."